what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and yesterday we talked
about Deadpool 3 we got an update from
its director Sean Levy and today we have
yet another update from Sean Levy
however this one is a little bit
different yesterday we got an update
involving Wolverine Logan although
something that he says in another recent
interview kind of implies that Logan and
Wolverine could be two different people
and in a movie where you're jumping into
different universes traveling the
Multiverse that could actually be true
but today's update is different it is
about the script and the rating of the
film of course everybody wants Deadpool
to remain rated R however since he is at
the Mouse's house now Disney fans were
wondering if Deadpool was indeed going
to remain rated R and a lot of changes
have taken place over at Disney recently
with the firing of Bob chapek and the
hiring where I should say rehiring of
Bob Iger he retired but they brought him
back to kind of fix everything but what
does that mean for Deadpool 3 is it
going to be rated R well Sean Levy
answers that question and a little bit
more about Deadpool in a recent
interview that we'll talk about today
also we're still doing a giveaway I have
chosen a winner for this week I'll
announce it at the end of this video but
we still have a lot to give away the
giveaway continues until the end of this
year so be sure to subscribe and leave a
comment down below to enter and again I
will announce winners in my videos that
way you know it's real and not a fake
giveaway scam because they are out there
sadly so right off the bat just good
news the movie is going to be rated R
Deadpool 3 is going to remain rated R
and it sounds like it's really really
good that it is because Sean Levy has
already begun to tease the violence and
the foulness of the movie violence of
course is expected it is Deadpool after
all but we're adding Wolverine to it so
I'm expecting some pretty graphic fight
scenes in this film plus not to mention
of course it's the Merc with the mouth
he's gonna have a lot to say and Sean
Levy is already promoting the soundness
and the violence in a recent interview
here's what he had to say we are writing
rewriting developing prepping Deadpool
every day now it is such a blast to
laugh every day it is so delicious to
hear and write and come up with these
scenes where people are just talking
foul and the violence is in your face
and hardcore and it is very much a
Deadpool movie and it has Logan in it
and it has Wolverine in it it's too fun
now that's that line that I mentioned in
the beginning where he talks about
Wolverine and he also talks about Logan
like they are two different people now
there could be more than one variant of
Wolverine Logan in the movie that is
entirely possible after all we know that
Deadpool and Wolverine Logan are going
to go on sort of a road trip and go to
many different universes until they
eventually end up in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so I would expect
that at some point in time they would
come across a different version of
Wolverine maybe even a different version
of Deadpool maybe Lady Deadpool but they
did say that they weren't going to undo
Logan and his death spoiler alert if you
haven't seen Logan they said they
weren't undoing any of that but I can
imagine a scene where Wolverine and
Deadpool do visit that Universe where he
dies and he kind of shows him his death
and kind of shows him hey look this is
your future this is the end for you
don't you want to change that however
they did say they weren't going to
change it so we'll have to see about
that but from the way it sounds there is
going to be more than one variant of
Wolverine in this film now he says a lot
more in this interview but real quick
let's go over when he says the violence
is in your face and hardcore and it's
very much a Deadpool movie and he talks
about people talking foul so this is
very much going to be much like the
first and second Deadpool film So for
anybody who was worried that they were
going to hold back their punches for
Deadpool 3 and even though it still is
rated RX still kind of hold back a
little bit and not go full rated R don't
worry anymore Sean Levy just gave us an
awesome update talking about how it's
going to be a true Deadpool movie and
the violence is going to be in your face
and we're going to hear so many great
Deadpool jokes that it's going to be
awesome but let's continue with this
interview with what Sean Levy had to say
he says I'm having so much fun and I
haven't even hit the shooting floor yet
I have to say developing a Deadpool
movie is one of the most fun creative
experiences of my life because it's not
just that it's rated R it's that it's so
filled with self-awareness and that
makes in writing very very fun in a way
that is unique to that franchise now of
course he is talking about Deadpool's
ability to break the fourth wall and due
to that fact it is a self-aware movie
Deadpool can speak to us directly the
audience and he can call out things
about the franchise about the other
franchises and you know he is going to
you know he's going to talk about the
fox franchise the MCU and probably all
of the past projects as well including
the old X-Men and the new X-Men coming
up after all She-Hulk did kind of
mention the new X-Men so I'm assuming
mean Deadpool is going to go even
further but here's something that he
ends up saying towards the end of the
interview that actually makes me kind of
sad and if some people have seen this
movie I think you'll relate with me but
it is very good news for Deadpool 3. he
said one of the few regrets in my career
is that I got strong armed into
re-cutting the internship from an R to a
PG-13 rating I still regret it because
the R-rated version of Vince Vaughn and
Owen Wilson in The Internship was way
better and the me of today would not
have succumbed like the meat of 20
whatever 12 years ago if you are not
familiar with the movie The Internship I
suggest you go watch it right now it is
a very funny movie and Owen Wilson and
Vince Vaughn are hilarious as always but
this does make me kind of sad he got
stronghold into making it PG-13 when I
know it could have been a lot funnier if
it was rated R but that is great news
for Deadpool that means that no matter
what happens Sean Levy and you know Ryan
Reynolds as well will not let Deadpool
be a PG-13 movie and it sounds like they
aren't going to hold back at all with
the humor and with the violence and
again I think this movie is actually
going to be more violent than the first
two Deadpool films that we had because
now we have Wolverine in this so I'm
expecting this movie to be like the
first two Deadpools combined with Logan
the movie that is so essentially a
really funny and sarcastic version of
Logan which I think everybody is going
to enjoy so great news for Deadpool 3
also we have to acknowledge this we kind
of have some historic Marvel news Iron
Man and the MCU now have historic
recognition the national film registry
released its 2022 selections and it
includes the historic edition of 2008's
Iron Man Iron Man now marks the first
MCU film to be added to the collection
of the national film registry which is
fantastic now it's not actually the
first superhero film to make it we have
1978 Superman and 2008's the Dark Knight
who are also on the list two legendary
films as well but of course this is our
first MCU film and our first Marvel film
on there so it's a great honor for the
MCU and Marvel and now it's a part of
film history the MCU has already been
historic on its own but it is good to
see it being recognized by the film
industry so that is really really
awesome so please let me know what you
think about these new Deadpool details
in the comments down below and a big
congratulations to YouTube user Marcus
Yates for winning our first Marvel
Legends giveaway we are going to
continue to do more giveaways until the
end of the year but congratulations to
Marcus Yates I've commented on your
comment on the YouTube channel giving
you my email address so please email me
and like I said for the rest of you we
are still giving away a few more Marvel
Legends items before the end of this
year we're gonna keep it going so all
you have to do is subscribe and comment
Down Below in my videos for a chance to
win don't forget to check us out on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
foreign